now normally the confirmation process to
anoint a new Secretary of Labor isn't
especially interesting we certainly
don't learn anything new or scandalous
most of the time but in 2017 the
confirmation process of Alexander aosta
was a very notable exception at the time
the Trump Administration was vetting
aosta and they asked him whether
anything in his past might pose a
problem during his confirmation hearings
and that's when aasta told Trump
officials about his handling of the
Jeffrey Epstein criminal case back when
he was the US attorney for the southern
district of Florida in 2007 alosta
recounted that he had agreed to give
Epstein like the mother of all
sweetheart deals he granted immunity not
only to Epstein but also to any
potential co-conspirators known or
unknown Costa also hid the existence of
this non-prosecution agreement from
Epstein's victims in violation of the
law as a result of the deal the federal
investigation into Epstein was shut down
Epstein ultimately pleaded guilty to a
state charge for procuring a girl for
prostitution under the age of 18 and he
was out of prison in a few months now
all of that was known to the Trump team
when they interviewed aasta these are
the kinds of facts that could have
killed his nomination to be Secretary of
Labor but aasta offered an explanation
for his handling of the Epstein case he
told investigators for the Trump
Administration that he had been directed
by us intelligence agencies to let
Epstein off the hook he was told that
Epstein quote belonged to intelligence
that the matter was quote above his pay
grade and that he needed to quote leave
it alone now when this news broke a
couple years later following Epstein's
arrest aosta was asked about it and uh
he refused to say that it was false he
gave maybe the most equivocal answer he
could have possibly given this will go
down in history as maybe one of the
worst attempts to evade an answer that
has ever occurred in a press briefing in
Washington which is really saying
something watch Mr secretary were you
ever made aware at any point your
handling of this case if Mr Epstein was
an intelligence asset of some sort
um so so so there has there has been
reporting to that effect and and let me
say um there's been reporting to a lot
of effects in in in this case uh not
just now but over the years and and
again I would you know I would hesitate
to take this reporting as fact um this
was a case that was brought by our
office it was brought based on the facts
and and I look at that reporting and
others I I can't address it directly
because of our uh our our guidelines um
but I can tell you that that a lot of
reporting is just going down rabbit
holes a few a few a few more questions
yes uh yes there's been reporting to
that effect but you know there's
reporting to a lot of
effects he actually said that and so
that's an admission obviously there's no
other way to interpret what aosta was
doing there he's not a particularly good
liar I mean if it didn't happen you know
then you just say no that's that's not
true so the non-
denial we can take reasonably as
confirmation that yes Jeffrey Epstein
was an intelligence asset he was being
used by the intelligence agencies and
therefore he couldn't go to prison for
amassing an army of child sex
slaves and that's not all the help that
um Epstein and his associates received
on July 6th and July 7th of 2019 shortly
after Epstein was arrested on new sex
assault charges FBI agents photographed
a variety of evidence in Epstein's New
York townhouse and they discovered
binders with CDs and photographs lining
the shelves inside a safe which they
opened with a saw the agents found uh
photographs of uh pornographic
photographs of children they also
discovered even more CDs that had
handwritten labels on them with the
names in some cases of two individuals
on some of the
labels now it's not hard to conclude
that this was probably blackmail
material according to the official story
agents simply photographed all of these
items but they claim they didn't take
them because they didn't have a search
warrant and Incredibly the agents left
the property to get a warrant which
somehow took 4 days to acquire so they
went there to raid the property they
found the stuff they said oh whoops we
never got a warrant and so they left the
stuff there for 4
days before they came back this by
itself is ridiculous since in a
high-profile case like this judges could
obviously have approved a warrant almost
immediately while agents remained on
site but in this case the agents left
the property and they didn't come back
until 4 days
later and by that point the materials
they had photographed were were missing
hm imagine that now supposedly one of
Epstein's lawyers later brought the
property to the FBI but of course
there's no way of knowing if the CDs
that they brought to the FBI if they
even brought them are the same ones that
were removed from the safe and we can be
pretty sure that they weren't there's no
way of knowing how much evidence was
tampered with but we can assume as
reasonable people that much of it
was now given this history there was
really no conceivable way that we're
ever going to learn the truth about
exactly what Jeffrey Epstein did and who
his associates
were um but in 2017 the independent
journalist Mike cernovich did his best
to get some answers anyway and me the
kind of thing that you would think like
the corporate media would be doing but
they have no interest cernovich did he
tried to force the government's hand he
filed an intervening Motion in an
existing defamation case concerning
Epstein and this motion which went all
the way up to federal appell court in
New York demanded that the government
release information it possessed about
Epstein and the courts ultimately agreed
but just days before documents were set
to come out coinc enough Epstein and
Epstein alone the only one was booked on
the new sex assault charges by the
federal government and so coincidentally
enough that arrest delayed the release
of the documents pending the prosecution
of course that prosecution never came
because Epstein quote unquote committed
suicide the materials in his safe
started to disappear outside of jiz Lane
Maxwell Epstein's Associates evaded
scrutiny and the the legal documents
containing the names of many Epstein
Associates as well as transcripts of key
witness depositions remained redacted
the holidays have come and gone and once
again you were very generous don't worry
though Pure Talk has your back instead
of paying your current cell phone
provider 60 70 or $80 per line Pure Talk
has unlimited plans starting at just $20
a month you'll get the same phenomenal
coverage you're used to on a America's
most Dependable 5G Den for just 20 bucks
a month this is how the average family
saves almost $11,000 a year it's time to
switch to a wireless company that shares
your values a company that isn't afraid
to invest in shows like mine a company
that is veteran-owned and serves
veterans so what are you waiting for
switch to Pure Talk in as little as 10
minutes and start saving today their Us
customer service team is waiting to
serve you go to Pur talk.com Walsh and
right now you'll save an additional 50%
off your first month that's Pur talk.com
Walsh to be connected now again Pur
talk.com / Walsh to start off the year
saving on wireless with a company you
can be proud of now last night after
many years of
delays we finally got a partially
unredacted look at some of the documents
that cernovich has been seeking for the
better part of a
decade uh and more documents are
expected to be unredacted in the coming
days and so this is just the first
batch but most of the material that
we're now allowed to see as you probably
guessed um most of this material is not
especially shocking in fact before any
of this was released I said on the show
a few days ago that if you're expecting
them to actually
release major like damning evidence
implicating high-profile people beyond
what we already knew if you were
expecting that then you have way more
faith in the system than you should
have and you know what I said at the
time is that most likely when this thing
comes out it is not even going to come
close to living up to the hype and it
appears that I was unfortunately correct
so we all knew for example that Bill
Clinton Bill Clinton had flown on
Epstein's private jet had been
photographed with some of Epstein's
victims um so we knew about that I mean
he should already be in prison it's not
ever going to happen what's new is
unredacted testimony from Johanna jerg
one of Epstein's victims and she was
asked quote did Jeffrey ever talk to you
about Bill Clinton in response Jer
testified that quote he said one time
that Clinton likes them young referring
to
girls now it's not clear whether the
testimony refers to underage
girls we can assume it does uh but nor
is this especially new information
that's the main thing neither is the
fact that according to one witness
Michael Jackson once visited Epstein at
his home in Palm Beach and to be sure
there are more alarming accusations in
these documents although for the most
part they aren't new there's the
testimony from Epstein victim Virginia
du fre that she was directed by jizan
Maxwell to have sex with prince Andrew
for example as well as hedge fund
manager uh Glenn Dubin uh so that's in
the
documents there're also renewed claims
in these documents that Harvard Law
Professor Alan dtz had sex with one of
Epstein's underage victims again we've
we've heard that claim before going down
the list the billionaire executive
chairman of hayatt hotels Thomas
pritsker is also alleged in these
documents have had sex with one of
Epstein's victims pritsker incidentally
is related to Illinois governor JB
pritsker as well as the Harvard board
member Penny pritsker who played a key
role in promoting claudian gay to the
Harvard presidency so in just in case
you thought this week somehow couldn't
get any worse for Harvard uh it just
continues now there are some modly
interesting tidbits all the same for
example the magician David copperfield's
name appears in these documents and he
appeared to be aware that Epstein was
recruiting underage girls uh there's no
direct evidence in the documents that
Copperfield himself engaged in illegal
activity there's also the news that
Epstein wrote an email explicitly
denying that Stephen Hawking had ever
participated in an orgy at his Island
which is like a strange email to write
you know that that's yes he's denying
it that in itself seems pretty damning
the only thing worse than being named in
an email by uh by Jeffrey Epstein as
having participated in one of his ories
is being specifically named as someone
who
didn't um but regardless this isn't
exactly groundbreaking stuff nor does it
provide much
Clarity and there are still many more
questions than answers if you go through
the nearly 600 page documents that were
released last night you'll still find a
lot of very conspicuous redactions on
page 497 for example you'll find this
question that was posed to Virginia je
fre says quote gizay Maxwell told you to
go give a massage to redacted correct
the name of the person is hidden and by
the same Tok on page 502 you'll find
this question to you FR other than Glenn
Dubin redacted prince Andrew uh Jean
Luke Brunell Bill richardon another
Prince the large Hotel chain owner and
the late MIT Professor Marvin Minsky is
there anyone else jizan Maxwell directed
you to go have sex with now once again
there's a name missing from the list in
that question and for some reason we're
still not allowed to know who that is
now there could be good reasons for
concealing some of the names maybe some
of the names are are underage victims of
abstein so are not being named that
makes
sense on the other hand maybe it's
someone with a lot of power who's still
under the control of the intelligence
agencies we really have no idea and
whatever the case there are a lot more
redactions like this you can download
the documents and see for yourself what
this means is that several years after
Epstein's death were still left to fill
in the blanks of these court documents
that were supposed to be made public
before Epstein died we're not entitled
to know anything more than basically
what we already
knew and we're definitely not allowed to
know what exactly was on those blackmail
CDs that disappeared mysteriously from
Epstein
safe but most of what appears in the
documents released yesterday leave
plenty of plausible deniability for
those named it's like none of it amounts
to actual solid proof of wrongdoing
again raising more questions than
answers but there's very good reason to
believe that there exists out there
somewhere or did exist at one point
actual physical direct proof that a
bunch of powerful people raped children
on Epstein's island or on one of his
other
properties like we we we know that that
exists or existed out there
somewhere but that proof is not being
released and nobody's ever been
arrested it's a funny thing isent
Epstein was an international pimp and
pedophile but apparently he had no
clients
the international pimp with no
clients I mean he was pimping out uh
these sex slaves but to
who apparently
nobody that's what we're supposed to
believe anyway but we can't believe that
because it's
nonsense which means that the truth the
real truth the full truth is still being
kept secret from us and those are
secrets as Alexander aasta said that are
above our pay grade quote unquote and
they will remain above our pay grade at
least until the people Epstein was
blackmailing step out of line then we
might see the names on some of those
CS then we might learn the identity of
at least some of the people in those
binders in his New York
townhouse otherwise the feds will
continue to Stonewall cernovich and
everyone else who's been seeking the
truth and that's because more than four
years after Jeffrey Epstein's death he
still belongs to the intelligence agency
you know the CIA has a term that maybe
you've seen
circulating over the last day uh it's a
term called limited hangout and this is
a tactic where some small portion of the
truth this usually happens when you know
when when when a cover is blown and
people know something's up the tactic is
to take some small portion of the truth
and make it public while the most
important details the stuff that really
matters uh the key information is still
kept hidden intelligence a agencies do
this in hopes that the stuff they
release will satisfy everyone's
curiosity and then they'll stop asking
questions these Epstein files appear to
be exactly that this is a limited
hangout a diversion meant to satisfy you
without actually telling you what you
need to know because they want you to
ask to stop asking
questions so don't fall for it thanks
for checking out this video if you'd
like to listen to my full podcast on the
go you can check out the Matt wall show
on Apple podcast Spotify or wherever you
get your podcasts